Now, some libraries are less about solving a particular domain of problems
and more about enabling the programmers to design their own solutions.
And I call these programming power tools,
and the first example I'm going to highlight is called Thrust.
Now, C++ programmers will know about the Standard Template Library, or STL.
STL provides a set of incredibly useful abstractions
that are organized into containers and iterators.
Thrust provides a data parallel analog to the STL for CUDA
and also borrows niceties from the popular Boost library.
Thrust allows host code that runs on the CPU
to very easily create and manipulate data on the GPU.
The principal container abstraction in Thrust is device vector,
and this is analogous to the vector container in STL,
but as the name implies, it lives on the device, on the GPU.
Like the STL vector container, Thrust device vectors are generic containers,
which means they're able to hold any data type and they can be resized dynamically.
So once your data is in a device vector, you can do a bunch of things trivially.
You can do things like sort the device vector or perform a scan operation on it,
you can do a reduction operation or a reduce-by-key operation
where you actually take a vector and reduce it according to a key that's in another vector.
So, for example, if you have a device_vector X--
in this case it's got 3 elements and it's of type float--
then I can do a reduction on those 3 elements
by just saying thrust::reduce, pass in x.begin and x.end
to indicate that I'm going to reduce over the entire range of the vector,
and it will give me the result.
Or you can do a reduction of a different sort.
So rather than simply doing a sum reduce, we can pass in an operator to use or a functor.
In this case we'll do thrust::maximum.
So in this case, this reduction will give us the maximum number in this vector.
You can also do more general transformations.
You can transform 1 or more input vectors into an output vector.
For instance, you could do a vector addition operation, taking 2 vectors
and adding them into a third vector using the built-in Thrust plus operator.
Or you can apply a user-defined transformation, using a functor,
and this is a chunk of code that you give Thrust and tell it, run this on every element
or on the collection of input and output elements that I'm interested in.
And you can interoperate with CUDA codes, so you can mix up Thrust code
which is running on the host and doing things on the device,
but if you then need to do something that is not built in to Thrust or that's difficult to do with Thrust
and you've got some raw CUDA kernels that you want to run,
then you can simply get the pointer to the data in a device vector
or hand a pointer to Thrust to wrap up as a device vector.
In the end, using Thrust is a good idea because it helps you avoid
writing a lot of error-prone sort of cut and paste boilerplate code,
and you can exploit high-performance implementations of these data parallel primitives
like sort and scan and reduce and reduce-by-key.
These have all been implemented by CUDA Ninjas for you so that you can just reuse that code.
So Thrust can be very handy.
We're going to give you Thrust code that sorts 10^6 floats,
and we're going to ask you to time it,
and then we're going to ask you to also time sorting 10^5 and 10^7 floats
and then enter here how long it took to sort 10^5 floats, 10^6 floats, 10^7 floats,
and 10^5, 10^6, and 10^7 bytes.
And enter your answer in milliseconds,
and we'll just check to within a significant digit or so.